♪♪♪
いやきたっしょ
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
本日はこちら
怖い...人が多い
最近そのー..うわああ
こんにちはー
最近ですねゲームセンターで
僕の人形、、パペットがUFOキャッチャーで取れるらしいので
ちょっと見に来てみました
あの実はまだ実際本物をちゃんと見てないので
果たしてどんな物かというのをちょっと確認しようと思いまして
あわよくば自分で取って持ち帰りたいので
僕のパペット,,ぬいぐるみがどんななのか見ていきたいと思います
ではいきましょう
はい！
おおー
1人2個まで
めちゃくちゃ可愛いな
ちゃんとTシャツ着てるTシャツ
すげー
トミックさん家で4000個ぶちまけたボールの僕バージョンと
トミックさんバージョンと
僕のパペットと
ところざわの小さい版の小ところざわの
2つのパペットがUFOキャッチャーで取れるみたいです
両方持ち帰っていいってことでしょ？
じゃまずオイラ自身を取ってから
小ところざわを取っていきます
めっちゃ100円玉準備したから多分いけると思います
さあいきましょう
まずは小手調べだよ
まず”はじめしゃちょー”から狙います
多分ねシンプルな作戦だと無理な気がするんだよね
どうだ
うわああ顔面が
やべーぞこれwwちょっと待って
やばいな
多分正攻法だと取れないやつだこれ
ちょっとづつずらしていく作戦だよ多分
2回目いきます
ずらしていく作戦が1番いい気がする
ほれほれほれ
きたきたきた
いや待ってちょっと待ってw
こんな難しいか？
やばいやばい
うおおおおおおおんんんうう
ムズいわ
あーもうちょい
もうちょい逆だったかな
ちょっと待ってホントに難しいんだけど
やばいべやばいべ
難しくね？これ
5回目
アームの横でちょっとづつずらしていった方がいい気がする
どうだ
あーまだもうちょいずらした方がいいのか
うぬんうぬんうぬうう
待wっwてw難wしwいwぞwこwれw
でもちょっとづつずれてるよね完全に
いやーこれ長期戦だわ
6回目いきます
この超超こっちより作戦
動け
*犬の鳴き声*
正攻法で取ろうとしても取れないんで
なに¿¿アームを使ってちょっとこう刺す感じ?¿
刺してずらしていけば多分取れます
めっちゃ動いたよ
もういけるでしょこれは
どうだい
頭に刺せれば動く
よしよしよし
ｲやすあーくりょうあーもういけるいける
もういけるよこれ
8回目です
どうや
どうやこれ
動け　おっしゃー
*歓喜*
よっしゃー
いえーーやばい
取れました
これパペットなんで中に手が入るんすよ
ほら
え、めっちゃ可愛くないすか？
俺と似ても似つかないな
はいというわけで”はじめしゃちょー”は800円でひとまず取ることができました
では小ところざわも取りましょう
コツを掴んだから多分さっきよりは安くいける気がする
いきます
鼻、鼻、鼻をぶっ刺してやるよ（やろう？）
動け
アーイッた///
でも動いた動いた
2回目
きたでしょう
うわーーこれも難しいなー
3回目いきます
どうだ
どうなんだこれ
前に出たか今？
出てないよね
あーもう目ブッさ刺しちゃったし
動いてるね確実に
もうイケる気はするんですよ
(´・ω・｀)ｼｮﾎﾞｰﾝ
きつないこれ？
しゃーこれはきたっしょ
はじパペ：これもう絶対イケるよね
*悲しい音楽*
もう取れますさすがに
はっはっはっはっはっ
やばいやばいやばい　鼻すれろ鼻すれろ
鼻すれろ
うーわこんこんなこんなのある？
ちょっと待ってw
引っかかってんじゃんw
*悲しい音楽*
多分頭を押し込めば取れるタイプなんですよ
次でトドメ刺そうと思います
これは完全にとらえた
うわーもうえっこれ
ドツボにハマってない？結構
13回目です
押し込め
いけ　いけ　体が
うーわダメかー
これは完璧　これはきた
刺した
腕を
うーーわ
体よじれてるw
きた　はうはうあはうあはうあはうあうあふあはう
( ^)o(^ )
逆にすごくない？これw
こんなことある？
ちょっと当たるだけでいいホントに
いけ
おっしゃーーー
*泣*
何円かかったのww
はいというわけで”小ところざわ”17回目で取れました
よかったです
2体取るのに25回分くらいかかっちゃいましたが
一応無事取れました
はいというわけで小ところざわとはじめしゃちょーパペットの他にも
ちょっと気持ち悪いボールもあります
こっちの方が取りやすいのかな
いいよいいい
今の見た？
顔バヨンッてなって取れたよ
全国のモーリーファンタジーさんのゲームセンターで取れるので
皆さんよかったら取ってみてください
じゃあな